طبعا الاسره من الاسرات ايضا كانت القديمه
موجوده في منطقه العارضه اللي هو الاسره
المالكه في جدهم الاعلى مانع المريدي وهذه
الاسره قديما كانت هنا في حجر اليمامه في
الرياض
في الرياض في في تقريبا قبل القرن ايضا
التاسع الهجري بعد تقريبا سنه 850
انتقلت هذه الاسره الى شرق الجزيره
العربيه لما ايضا الصيدلات الموجوده بين
ايضا هذه المنطقه وايضا بمنطقه الاحساء
وكما نعلم ايضا ابن مقرب العيوني الشاعر
الدوله العيونيه في الاحساء كان هنا ايضا
في الرياض في حجر اليمامه ولهذا كانت له
قصائد ايضا التبادل التجاري وايضا التبادل
الحضاري فيما بين هذه المنطقه العارضه
ايضا الاحساء الاتصال وادوات التواصل
قريبه اما سياسيا وايضا دينيا واجتماعيا
وثقافيا وغير اقتصاديا ولهذا انتقل افراد
من هذه الاسره المالكه عندما كانوا هنا في
حجر اليمامه انتقلوا الى الاحساء واستمر
الى ابناء عمومتهم لان هذه الاسره تنتسب
الى قبيله بني حنيفه وهذه القبيله هي
المسيطره على هذه المنطقه منذ الجاهليه
وايضا الاسلام وحتى الفترات القريبه الى
يومنا الحاضر لان هذه الاسره هذه مواطنهم
القديمه
كونها قبيله حضريه حاولت ايضا الانتشار في
هذا الوادي منذ قبل الاسلام الى الفترات
الحاليه فالشاهد هنا انتقال هذه الاسره
السعوديه الى الاحساء ثم
بداتهم الاعلى مانع المريدي جدهم الاعلى
فصار هناك تواصل بين هذا الجد الاعلى
للاسره السعوديه مانع المريدي وبين ايضا
امير الرياض ابن عمهم عبد المحسن بن سعيد
الدرعي الحنفي فكان هذا التواصل والاتصال
فيما بينهم ثم اقترح ايضا في هذا التواصل
كما يقول المؤرخون لما بين الاثنين من
المواصله والمراحمه وكونهم ايضا من هذه
القبيله فانتقل بالتالي جد الاسره المالكه
مانع المريدي الى بعد ما طلبه ابن عمه ان
يقضعه ارضا فاقطعه ارض شمال حجر اليمامه
وشمال الرياض التي هي تقريبا الان الدرعيه
التي قامت على موضع قديم يسمى موضع الضيق
وغبيره كان هذا اسم الجاهليه وايضا واول
الاسلام ثم تحول الى المليبيد وغصيبه
الان في الدرعيه تقع في الجهه الجنوبيه
منها في موضع يقال له العلاقيه واما غصيبه
فايضا في موقع الطريف من ناحيه الشماليه
في يقال له
يعني الموضع الشاهد هناك غصيبه فالدرعيه
تكونت من عده احياء كان اسمها قديم كما
ذكرت الضيق وغبيره ثم اصبح المليبيد
وغصيبه وبعض الاحيان يطلق على المليبيت
الملابيت بصفه الجمع او المليبد بصفه ايضا
المفرد ثم في هذه الفتره التاريخيه انتقل
ايضا جد الاسره السعوديه واستقر هناك مانع
بن ربيع مانع المريدي ابنه ربيعه انتقل
لسنه 800 تقريبا وخمسين من الهجره وبدا
ايضا هذا الاستيطان اعاده الاستيطان ايضا
لهذه المنطقه وبالتالي انتشر هذا الذريه
هذه الاسره اذا هذا الموضع من الاساس وهو
تسكنه اسر من بني حنيفه الذي صنعه مانع
المريدي هو انه اعاد احياء سنه موجوده
وقديمه وكان هذا الوادي ايضا نفوذه او
يفوز فيه لاسر بني حنيفه في دليل تسميته
الميزه التي تقع على هذا الجانب بهذا
الوادي وايضا بما يحمله من الصفات ايضا
الاقتصادي والزراعيه وايضا الحضاريه هو
قديم العهد يعني ليس بجديدا ولهذا اغلب
المدن تقع على اطرافه في الجهه من الجهه
الغربيه او الشرقيه ولهذا تاتي اهميته
ايضا من ضمن هذه المراه